I don't want to start on a down note but
a friend of mine just got dumped yeah I
know everybody feels bad for the person
that gets dumped and I do too but you
know who I also feel bad for the dumper
how do you say that
don't be gross is that what I meant the
one who does the dump no it still sounds
like poo the one who makes dump okay the
breaker upper the breaker it's hard to
be the breaker upper and I'm tired of
not talking about it in fact tonight I'm
going to take the controversial opinion
and say it's easier to be the person
getting dumped in some instances I know
it's hard for both parties but when you
get dumped all you have to do is get
dumped but the person dumping somebody
has to dump somebody is there anything
more excruciating than knowing you're
about to surprise someone with
heartbreak someone you care about you're
just lurking in the shadows with a
dagger that says we need to talk
nightmare I had to break up with
somebody about a year ago it wasn't a
long-term thing we had only gone out a
handful of times but we'd slept together
in upwards of two positions and I'm old
fashioned to position sex means you got
to break up in person I was raised right
so on Saturday I called her like ring
ring hello it's Pete that's a red flag
right there calling someone you've never
called before ever up until that point
it's entirely texting and most of those
texts are emojis
but you can't break up like that just
like broken heart frowny face poop pile
with the smiley face she'll get the
message so I got a caller natural just
like hey it's totally normal calling you
11 a.m. on Saturday yeah you wanna meet
for lunch or coffee or you know some
other activity we've never done before
listen carefully if you're seeing
somebody and it's all been dinners and
drinks and all of a sudden they want to
share a neutral location daytime scone
with you
breakup detected get out of that zone
get out of the scone zone I had to make
a plan with her to get coffee that's
right
I made an appointment to break up I even
put it in my phone like Saturday hurt
Linda I phone all day and the day
finally comes I'm driving over
rehearsing trying to find the perfect
words talking to myself just like I
can't I can't I can't I can't do this
anymore no no that feels like
three-position sex I want out what is
this the Mafia
I'm moving to Ecuador oh that's it I'm
moving to Ecuador to see other people
and you got a fantasize trying to
envision how they might take it that's
not fun
best-case scenario they're okay with it
that's the fantasy or hoping for she
says she wants to break up at the exact
same moment you're saying it and you're
like jinx
actually I'm gonna drink it by myself
we've been spending way too much time
together but it's much more likely that
they'll take it badly you drop the bomb
and there's a long silence Yuri silence
like a Silence of the Lambs silence her
upper lip starts quivering like Elvis
mid croon you know something's coming
all you can do is slowly back away like
she's holding a detonator or you could
take it really badly just doesn't say
anything just stands up walks to the
nearest mirror and starts hitting
yourself like Mark Wahlberg in fear I'm
gonna go but the person being dumped
doesn't have to worry about any of this
getting dumped is just like being snowed
in there's nothing you can do all you
have to do is sleep wear sweatpants and
eat frosting straight from the can you
even get to call someone an when
they're breaking up with you when do you
get to do that I can really mean it like
your Oscar winning moment just like you
even though you're hurt in the back you
mind you're like I am mailing this and
there are other benefits too everybody
knows you're sad because you got dumped
so now you can cancel any activity and
no one gives you any you've got a
cast-iron excuse people are like yeah I
really do I do I want to come over and
go to your poetry slam
but I've recently been emotionally
eviscerated here's why it's easier most
people I think are really bad at hurting
other people but everybody's a natural
at feeling sad you know what to do
there's moot motels there's alcohol and
sympathetic bartenders sad music there's
no music for people doing the breaking
up it'd be helpful like new from you to
the hit song just because something ends
doesn't mean it was a failure it's not
catchy but it's helpful to remember and
from John Mayer just remember when she
said all that means stuff about your mom
and then the classic Phil Collins
breakup song she was kind of a turd
[Applause]
[Music]